hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen zieht vorstellung kleber
zeit endlich mal wieder die letzte war
ja gar nicht so lange her ich habe
versprochen dass ich in der 1.5 mehr
sieht vorstellungen machen wollen würde
keine ahnung wer das komplette system
wieder umgekrempelt wurde und man
deswegen wieder wirklich eine menge
neues finden kann
wenn ihr irgendwelche zwist dann könnt
ihr mir die wie immer in die kommentare
schreiben und eventuell stelle ich die
dann mal wieder in einem video vor
dieser sieht den habe ich aus der sicap
die ich für mein handy habe und ich
wollte ihnen mal vorstellen der heißt
nicht sieht sondern der heißt 11 95 40
75 112 86 87 6 4 1 das ist der sieht
könnt euch einfach hier abschreiben
steht aber auch unten in der
beschreibung und dann würde ich sagen
scheint ihn einfach ab und ihr musste
auf welt nicht auf standard nicht auf
superflach sondern auf große biome gehen
dann können uns die welt hier erstmal
erstellen so ist vorn jetzt ungefähr
wenn die welt sich verladen würde genau
hier spawn ck hier also ungefähr uhr
anbauen irgendwie hier so im bio ich
habe den film schon mal getestet aber
nicht da in gisbourne vorhin wenn ich
mal da hinten gespannt ist jetzt auch
relativ egal jedenfalls könnte f3
drücken und dann seht ihr links
hier seht ihr war 3 ist f2 north ihr
guckt zwischen nordosten so dahin und
fliegt da einfach mal hin
beziehungsweise dem survival mode seid
könnt ihr auch einfach hin laufen bei
mir ruckelt raten bisschen weil die welt
aufgebaut wird und ich nebenbei noch
ändere wenn wir hier allerdings sind
fliegen wenn wir hier schon ein ganz
kleines npc dorf das ist aber gar nicht
als highlight dieses sieht denn direkt
neben diesem mpc doch sehen wir hier
eine komische konstruktion und genau
hier ist befindet sich ein spanner bei
vielen bei mir was ist jetzt von anfang
an zombies bonner gewesen ich hab in der
seed abstand das ist ein 1 baiersbronner
sein soll
ihr müsst ihr jedenfalls ein bisschen
rum graben damit ihr an die kisten kommt
ihr vergraben sind
und zwar ist es nur eine kiste die hier
ist es irgendwie komisch und in der
kiste hand ist nichts besonderes drin
außer dieses verzauberte buch mit einem
feuerschutz von 4 war es glaube ich ja
genau von 4
und ja hier ist halt der eschborner
gleich angrenzend auch noch an die
kleine höhle die wir da und noch weiter
könnt ihr einfach mit diesen durch
graben
wir haben ganz normales dörfchen wo ihr
einfach mit den leuten hier gewissen
handeln könnte natürlich ganz ganz viele
preise 30 aktiv für eine schere das
natürlich super würde ich auf jeden fall
mit handeln ja mehrere stunden bisschen
suite falls solchen bauen wollte wieso
wir können sich einfach mal reingehen
und in der pyramide sind auch eigentlich
ganz coole sachen wenn man hat auf jeden
fall einen diamanten da drin was ich
sehr schön finde ich habe ja das glück
dass ich so coole sachen in der vorrunde
finde hier ist jetzt auch nicht so toll
allerdings hinter halb zwei diamanten
drin
hier in der letzten kiste da sind zwei
diamanten und drei akte und ich würde
sagen da wir ja so gut sind im handeln
tauschen wir die drei smaragde doch erst
mal direkt gegen die schere das ist auch
einfach super also diese preise
radarwarner krebs gregor das ist doch so
interessant da nehme ich mir direkt von
der schere also das war doch mal ein
gutes angebot also hier sind auf jeden
fall schon mal ein paar coole sachen
drin fünf gold 25 knochen eine schere
also eigentlich drei smaragde zwei
diamanten sattel 6,4 weizenbrot redstone
14 ein verzaubertes buchen feuerschutz
vier verrottetes fleisch 9 10 und 11
eisenbahn kann man sich schon ein
bisschen was daraus zaubern wenn man
hier allerdings weiter fliegt so im
südosten so ein bisschen in die richtung
sind wir hier grenzen erstmal drei bio
man einander also hier ein studium ein
ganz neues jung und wüstenblume wenn wir
ein wenig weiter fliegen seht ihr jetzt
schon ein wenig am horizont kleben
selbst kleben wir haben was ein riesiger
krater bzw
ein riesiger krater sondern zwei
risikograd die sind irgendwie zusammen
hier ist ein krater und hier ist genau
die mitte habe ich auch noch nicht
gesehen wollte jetzt rationiert
links fehler war da saß dieser leitlinie
fehler die sind auch immer noch
vorhanden verstehe nicht warum sie nicht
einfach mal raus nehmen wir auch wieder
ein paar blöcke kaputt machen
funktioniert das leibchen wieder
also wir haben hier wirklich einen
riesigen krater einerseits und hier sein
doppelter krater kann man sich bestimmt
irgendwas kitschiges mit blas darüber
bauen und auch allgemein hier die region
finde ich sehr schön zum hin pflanzen
oder sich irgendwie einbauen will finde
ich sehr schön hier irgendjemand hier
sind weg darüber bauen hier ein riesiger
krater und keine ahnung
ja auch noch weitere höhen eingänge zu
den anliegenden höhlen kann man auf
jeden fall ein paar schönen ärzte darin
finden und ja das war's mit diesem zieht
um den noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen haben einen doppelten
krater hier indem ihr einfach nach
südosten fliegt vom ntc village was von
spawn aus im nordosten liegt und an dem
an dem dorf angrenzend haben wir noch
einen ein monster stoner der sich hier
in einer sand konstruktion befindet und
noch dort eine pyramide in der er unter
anderem zwei diamanten und drei emirates
findet also das war es dann auch mit
dieser vorstellung ich hoffe euch
ausgefallen wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann würde ich mich über einen daumen
hoch freuen
das zeigt mir dass ihr weitere
vorstellungen volt und der oder
verzögert gefallen hat und wenn jetzt
wisst wie ihr der breiten öffentlichkeit
präsentieren möchte da die anderen wie
vielleicht noch nicht kennen und
vielleicht kennenlernen sollten dann
könnt ihr auch einfach unten in die
kommentare schreiben und mich sagen wir
beim nächsten mal noch einen schönen tag
und wir sind morgen wieder bei cds